il ne passe pas inaperçu le long de la
rd 181 6 5 centres de dépistage du coc
vite 19 ait installé sur l'un des
parkings extérieurs de parly 2 du côté
de l'arboretum de chèvreloup une
initiative lancée depuis le 19 octobre
dernier en partenariat avec la ville du
chesnay rocancourt donc on a été
sollicité la mairie la ville du coup du
chéné rocancourt en lui proposant de
leur mettre à disposition un terrain
puisqu'on en a de disponible et puis en
fait oui ce film parly 2 c'est aussi un
point névralgique des yvelines donc
c'était une façon d'accueillir en fait
les personnes les patients pour cette
unité mobile plus facile 6 jours sur 7
entre 100 et 120 personnes se font
dépister gratuitement chaque jour dans
cette structure de 20 m² le matin à
partir de 9 heures sans rendez-vous il
après midi sur rendez vous la réponse
aux tests est donné sous 72 heures très
rapides très efficaces bien reçus on est
bien accueilli c'est bien expliqué
franchement c'est parfait mais c'est
vachement bien parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'attentât contrairement aux
laboratoires
oh bah je trouve une très bonne
initiative elles sont toutes bonnes à
prendre ce moment le rendez vous était
rapide donc oui je recommande la
structure sera présente au minimum
jusqu'à la fin novembre le dispositif
pourrait être sûrement étendue au delà
de cette date
au total le département compte près
d'une quarantaine de centres de
dépistage